Theresa is whether some Midland Texas I
Theresa how are you doing great I had to
talk to you Dave you too what's up um I
was going to find out we're doing the
baby steps and we're on baby steps - and
it seems like when you start paying up
the smallest bit everyone starts coming
out the woodwork
so what I need to find out is I'm
everyone's hide out of the woodwork are
you talking about you got old bad debt
yes and we're paying off our debt the
smallest to the largest
mm-hm and I have received being sued by
company they've retained an attorney and
I do know I owe the debt but they're six
on the line though they won't get paid
himself we get down to them but the
amount is two thousand nine hundred and
sixty nine ninety four and I want to
know they've given me the attorneys
number and I have 14 days to reach
fawned I can either go to court or I can
respond to the attorney and settled the
dead so my question is how much of what
kind of payoff should I offer okay is
there a court date on this document no
it just says that it's 14 days from the
time I was summoned and I received the
papers on Tuesday you you were summoned
like the Sheriff's Department yes there
was um there was a court officer who
brought me the papers okay okay do you
have any money saved we have a thousand
dollars and I have seven and we have
seven hundred cash okay then you could
offer them seventeen hundred right we
could yes okay yeah I'd probably call an
offer if you can settled 2904 seventeen
hundred I would get it out of order and
they're baby steps for me and it gets
rid of it gets rid of a court situation
for you okay obviously you need to get
it in writing before you give them money
and under no circumstances do you give
them electronic access to your checking
account
okay no no do you think there would be
any way that they could that they would
go any lower than that
or well what I would do is ask them for
an offer I wouldn't make an offer I
would just call up and go I don't have
$2,900 what's the very best y'all can do
and whatever they say listen to me
carefully
whatever number they give you I don't
care if it's five hundred bucks okay
don't jump on it whatever number they
give you go can you do any more and just
see what they say it doesn't cost a
thing that's right right and let's just
say we do because my guess is is the
original debt was a lot lower than that
they've added a bunch of fees in here
yes because I do remember if I'm not
mistaking the company that it is coming
from last time I remembered that that
was nine hundred and a few dollars yeah
and they've got it all jacked all the
way up to three thousand so yeah I'm
gonna try to settle this for seven eight
hundred bucks then okay
and I don't want to pay more than the
original debt for sure so they were
absolutely jacked you with these fees
then okay so when he does make that
offer do I tell him before I send him
the money that they need to send me a
letter agreeing to that yeah an email
would be fine okay an email would be
fine yeah with them as long as you've
got proof that you had a in writing that
you had something from and you keep a
copy hard copy of that email with a copy
of the cashier's check stapled to it and
you send them a cashier's check
overnight mail but no electronic access
to your checking account okay no we we
don't need any more they'll clean them
out yeah you don't you don't want to do
it and so this is probably a collections
company that has a law firm wrapped into
it okay so you're not eating with you're
not dealing with Matlock here okay you
see what I'm saying so this is a this is
a collections agency that has a lot of
people sitting around in cubicles with
headsets on call
and bothering people all day and they
have one lawyer in the mix in the back
corner okay this is not a law firm
that's big and scary
this is barnyard law you follow me okay
so we don't be intimidated by the fact
that it came from a lawyer okay because
they give the address up in Carrollton
yeah and in Texas they cannot garnish
your wages okay so they're not kind
there's not going to get anything out of
you if they play hardball so they would
like to take a thousand dollars here
it'd be a really good deal for you and a
really good deal for them and that's how
you work this but no matter what they
say just go you doing it better and see
what you come up with and just work it
down get it in writing and then send the
cashier's check or it's stapled to the
email and you keep a copy of the
cashier's check stapled to a hard copy
of the email in a file for the rest of
your life any time you settle a debt
because it will come back up this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]